[Music]
foreign
which are the 11 dragons missing from
the first season of House of the Dragon
well let's tell you the ones that did
not make an appearance and whether they
will do so in future Seasons let's get
to it
number one Silverwing let's start with a
pale silver shade dragon and she is
Silverwing and one of the riderless
dragons in Dragonstone at the end of the
first season she along with vermouth
would be claimed in the second season by
bus is called off the white and Hugh
Hammer respectively Silverwing is a
large Dragon an old dragon as well one
of the first generation dragons to be
born after aegon's Conquest she has been
described as a silvery dragon and was
considered relatively docile and
friendly to strangers
number two the cannibal one of the
oldest if not the oldest dragon and
probably one of the biggest as well in
Westeros the cannibal is the largest of
the wild dragons of Dragonstone and is a
feared Beast he eats whatever he wants
he is mentioned by Damon in the last
episode although not by name alongside
two other dragons unfortunately this
Dragon will not be claimed by anyone and
would remain Wild
number three sheep stealer sheep stealer
was a hideous mud Brown Dragon uh he was
not violent towards people unless
provoked he had a taste for mutton and
would also eat an occasional sheepdog on
the way but would never hurt a shepherd
ship stealer was well over 50 years old
when Nettles born with him thus he was a
mature Dragon dream fire on one hand who
was much older than sheep still was
regularly characterized as Slim and
large thus sheep stealer may have also
been the same
number 4 Greg host Greg host was a faint
gray white dragon like the morning myth
he was a bashful dragon that avoided
Mankind and their efforts for years at a
time earning him the moniker the great
host cause he was out there gray and
like a ghost he was one of the three
wild dragons alongside sheep Steeler and
a cannibal and was never claimed or
written by any man the crew of the
nissaria a ship witnessed Greg hoes and
another Dragon Battle in the sky over
the dragonmon in 130 AC and the dragon
was killed during the battle and
devoured by Sunfire
number five dyraxes this Dragon was not
seen in season 1 but was said to have
been bonded with Joffrey valerion the
third child of Queen rhaenera teraxis
was a young dragon and was growing at a
far space but was still smaller than
Vermax and even a-rax by the time of the
dance of the Dragons he had recently
been able to fly long distances with his
rider but was not quite big enough for
combat thus he would be seen in season 2
with a young prince Joffrey
number six morning this was the youngest
dragon that would be seen in the series
and would probably only make an
appearance until the final season of the
show morning was a she Dragon which had
during the dance of the dragons and
belonged to Reina Targaryen the daughter
of Prince Damon Targaryen and Lena
valarion morning is going to be a pale
pink dragon with black horns and a white
chest she would also be the only
surviving Targaryen Dragon after the war
number 7 deserion the blue Queen is
definitely one to look out in the next
season the sarin was a lovely blue she
Dragon her wings were deep cobalt blue
while her claws crass and belly scales
were a vivid hammered copper her Flames
were also supposed to be Cobble blue in
color but we will only see normal Flames
during the dance of the Dragons she was
the youngest Dragon of fighting weight
belonging to Prince Daron of the greens
she would take part in a deadly battle
that would end in Three Dragons dying
because of it
number eight Moon Dancer she was a
graceful and very Nimble she dragon that
was written by Bella Targaryen and will
be seen in the next season Moon Dancer
was a slender pale green uh her horns
crests and Wing Bones were Pearl in
color she was very quick both in the sky
and on the ground she was mentioned by
Damon in the last episode and therefore
would make her debut in Season 2. and
here she would probably go to battle
against Sunfire and aegon II
number nine storm cloud this is the
dragon that was hatched and Bonnet with
aegon the younger the younger son of
renera Targaryen who would become the
King after the war although in the books
both aegon and the dragon were old
enough to ride and fly in the air by
themselves in the show however aegon was
still seen as a toddler and stormcloud
might only be seen till the third season
or so
number 10 more girl he was a young
dragon bound too but never ridden by
Princess jehera Targaryen as Sally not
much stated about the dragon but that he
was locked in the dragon pit with dream
fire sea smoke terraxis and shrikas
Markle would be killed in a dragon pit
in the storming by a huge mob of people
from King's Landing
and number 11 strikas she was another
young dragon that was bonded to one of
the twin children of aegon II Bonner to
Prince jehair's Targaryen and not much
is known about this Dragon just as not
much is known about Marvel but that she
would be killed in a dragon pit with
several others as she was locked there
she would probably be seen till the
third season
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam